المترجم: Nawal Sharabati
المدقّق: muhammad Samir
دعونا نسأل في البداية من معنا اليوم
يعرف الملك تحتمس الثالث؟
تقريباً، أربعة، خمسة
من أصل 300.
حسناً من يعرف صلاح الدين الأيوبي؟
كُلنا، كُلنا نعرف صلاح الدين الأيوبي.
لماذا يعرف الجميع صلاح الدين الأيوبي
البطل العربي العظيم؟
لكننا لا نعرف تحتمس الثالث، مع أنه أهم
كثيرًا في تاريخ بلدك من صلاح الدين الأيوبي
ليس السينما وكتاب الدراسات فقط.
تحتمس الثالث واحد من
أهم الأباطرة على مستوى العالم.
تحتمس الثالث هو أول فرعون
مصري أسّـس جيش نظامي.
وطّور الجيش المصري جدًا
وقام بـِ 16 حملة، انتصر خلالها كلها.
ليس هذا فقط، تُحتمس الثالث
الفرعون الأسطورة
الذي عندما علم
أنّ جيوش آسيا كلها تتحالف ضده
لم يكتفِ بتأمين حدودنا الشرقية،
بل وصل إليهم
وانتصر على 23 جيشًا موحدًا في
معركة قادش.
تحتمس الثالث هو الفرعون الأسطورة،
تحتمس الثالث رجل عظيم
يستحق منا جميعا أن نعرفه
لكننا للأسف لا نعرفه
ذلك لأننا نعتبر أنفسنا عرب مصريين
أو مصريين عرب؟
هل نحنُ مصريون عرب أو
عرب مصريون؟
مصريون عرب، صح؟ ما هي هويتنا؟
مصرية في المقام الأول أوعربية؟
ماذا تعني هُويّة أصلًا؟
هُوية مشتقة من كلمة هُو
هو، ما هو؟ ما هي هويته
ما أنت؟ ما نحنُ؟
عرب أو مصريون؟
حسناً، يقول العرب أنّ كل
من يتحدث (ينطقُ) العربية فهو عربي،
أرى أن هذه القاعدة ليست سليمة،
لأنه لو صحّت هذه القاعدة،
إذاً المواطن السنغالي الذي يتحدث
الفرنسية، يصبح فرنسياً،
والكاميروني الذي يتحدث الإنجليزية
يصبح إنجليزياً
بالطبع لا.
وبالتالي، حتى لو صحّت القاعدة وقلنا
أن المواطن
الذي ينطق العربية هو عربي،
إذاً, نحن لا نتكلم العربية.
نحنُ نتكلم العامية المصرية،
العامية المصرية خليط من اللغة العربية
واللغة القبطية،
والفرعوني القديم والتركية.
نحنُ نتكلم الهيروغليفية كثير
جدًا على فكرة،
نحنُ نقول "نونو" بمعني صغير،
ونقول "بخ" للدهشة
ونقول "بُعبُع" بمعني شئ مرعب مجهول،
ونقول "بس" بمعني كفي.
نقول "مَم" بمعني أكل و"إمبو" بمعني إسقني
كل هذا فرعوني على فكرة،
نقول "ياما" يعني كثير،
نقول الأمطار"بترُخ" يعني تتساقط.
نقول "بطّت" جعلته مسطحا
و"بطح" أصاب رأسه و"طنش" لم يعره إهتمام
كل هذا ا كلام فرعوني.
نقول "كاني وماني" ، "إديلو إدي"،
هذا فرعوني على فكرة
نحنُ نتكلم فرعوني.
(ضحك)
"إدلوا إدي" ليس "عبيله وإديله".
حسناً، وبعيدًا عن موضوع اللغة.
لو اعتبرنا أن الكتب السماوية،
مراجع تاريخية.
تقول الكتب السماوية أنّ إبراهيم
إنتقل من بلاد الشام إلى مصر.
وأهداه الملك المصري جارية مصرية
هي هاجر،
وبعد أن تزوجها وأنجبت اسماعيل
سافر معها إلى شبه الجزيرة العربية،
كانت شبة الجزيرة العربية في ذلك الوقت
وادٍ غير ذي زرع،
ونحنُ نعرف أنّ الإستقرار
مرتبط بالزراعة.
لا يوجد زرع ، لا يوجد بشر
لا يوجد أناس.
وبالتالي فهاجر واسماعيل هما
منَ عمرا شبه الجزيرة العربية
معنى ذلك أن العرب كلهم أبناء هاجر المصرية.
فلماذا لا ندركُ ذلك؟
لماذا لا ندركُ أنّ حضارتنا أولى لنا
أن نعتز بها لأنها هي الأصل وهي الأساس.
أنتم تنتمون إلى حضارة من بين أربع أو
خمس حضارات على مستوى العالم كله،
شكّلت هوية البشرية كلها.
نحنُ أول منْ عرف التدوين.
هل تعرفون ما هو التدوين؟
نحنُ دائماً نقول كلمة ما قبل التاريخ،
ماذا نقصدُ بـِ "ما قبل التاريخ؟"
نقصدُ ما قبل التدوين.
أجدادك هم اللذين اخترعوا التدوين،
أجدادك هم الذين اخترعوا الفن،
أجدادك هم الذين اخترعوا التقويم،
وما زال التقويم المصري هو
أدق تقويم.
كان أجدادك سباقون في كل شيء،
في كل العلوم، في الطب، في الزراعة،
في العمارة، في الهندسة.
كانت على أرض مصر أول عملية جراحية
في المخ.
فالمجتمع الأوروبي الذي نتكلم عنه
طوال الوقت،
على أنه مجتمع راقٍ جدًا وعظيم،
ولا بدّ لنا أن نقتدِ به،
لم يستطع حتي هذا اليوم أن يصل للرقي
الذي وصل إليه المجتمع المصري.
يًقاس رقي الحضارات كلها باحترامها
للمرأة واحترامها لمبدعيها،
المرأة في المجتمع المصري لم تكن تُحترم
في الطبقات المخملية فقط،
كانت تُحترم في كل الطبقات.
على أرض مصر، كانت أول قاضية في
تاريخ البشرية.
على أرض مصر، كانت المرأة إلهه مقدسة،
لم تكن عورة،
نحنُ أول منْ عرف الدين.
أول منْ عرف الآلهه،
أول من عرف التوحيد.
إذاً أنتَ في المقام الأول
مصري أو عربي؟
أنتَ مصري والمفروض أن تعتز
بكونك مصري.
أقول لكم هذا الكلام اليوم،
لأنه يجب علينا أن ندرك هذا،
ونعتز بهويتنا ونتجه إليها من جديد.
يجب علينا أن نُدرس في مدارسنا مثل ما
ندرس التاريخ العربي،
والتاريخ المصري الحديث كله.
يجب أن يكون هناك فصل مقرر على كل سنة
دراسية يتحدث عن التاريخ الفرعوني فقط،
يجب أن نعرف أجدادنا.
يجب أن ندرس علومهم التي حيّرت العالم
إلى اليوم.
يجب أن نحتفل بأعيادهم.
لقد أصبحتم تحتفلون بكل الأعياد،
أنتم تحتفلون بالهالوين حالياً.
هل تعرفون ما هو الهالوين؟
لم يبقَ عليكم إلاّ أن تحتفلوا بعيد الشكر
وعيد الإستقلال الأمريكي.
لماذا لم نحتفل برأس السنة الفرعونية؟
لماذا لا نحتفل برأس السنة الفرعونية؟
لماذا لا نُلفت نظر العالم إلينا؟
"ها نحنُ نحتفل برأس السنة الفرعونية."
ونقيمُ مهرجانات وحفلات في ذلك اليوم.
لماذا لا نلفتُ نظر العالم كله إلينا؟
ونقول لهم ها نحن هنا موجودون.
نحنُ مصريون.
نحنُ أبناء الآلهه.
هويتي وهويتك مصرية.
شكرًا.